ALEXIS: Hello, everyone.
I'm here again with Francois.
Hi, Francois.
FRANCOIS: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
ALEXIS: Not bad.
So we're here today to
talk about extensions
versus Chrome applications.
There are subtle or
important differences
that we think you
should be aware of.
And Francois will
help you and me
understand what those
differences are.
So Francois, let's start
probably with extensions.
They were the ones that
were the first ones around.
And as the name
implies, they were
extensions to the browsers.
FRANCOIS: Yeah.
ALEXIS: Tell us more about
what they really are.
FRANCOIS: So
basically, extensions
extend functionality
for the Chrome browser.
They have no UI
at all, actually.
For instance, let's take
this Gmail extension,
which is the browser action.
You can see it all the time.
ALEXIS: It's associated with
the browser instance itself.
FRANCOIS: Next to
the Chrome menu.
ALEXIS: Not for a given page.
FRANCOIS: Next one
is the RSS extension.
Pretty simple.
you will see this icon only when
the web page has an RSS feed.
ALEXIS: OK.
FRANCOIS: And so this is
a kind of UI you can get,
or sometimes you
don't have anything.
Like for instance, AdBlock.
ALEXIS: Right.
FRANCOIS: It works
under the hood,
and gets all the
requests, and filters out
all the ads, for instance.
ALEXIS: Right.
So I suppose here, what
you want is something
that extends the
functionality of a browser,
but is not a full
fledged application.
If you want to do a full
fledged application,
there at these two
types of applications
that people can consider.
The first one is called
hosted applications.
So these are just
typical websites,
but with a little
bit of metadata.
Tell us more about what this is.
FRANCOIS: Yeah.
A hosted app is a
regular web page,
so it works online,
plus some metadata,
like some permissions
that have been
granted to the application.
So let's take, for
instance, Google Drive.
Google Drive is a perfect
example of a nice hosted app.
It has the storage permission,
the notification permission,
the clipboard permission.
And basically, once
you know you've
got this permission
for free, you
won't be prompted
by Chrome, OK, do
you want to, blah, blah, blah.
ALEXIS: But as a user, I develop
the application just once.
The experience of the user
is a little bit different,
in the sense that
the user is not
prompted every time for
the specific permissions
if it's a hosted application.
So as you said, this is
for online applications.
So clearly a hosted application
lives in the browser
and works online.
Which brings us to the third
type of extension in general.
But those are packaged
extensions, or Chrome apps.
One thing that makes them
different from the others
is the fact that
they're offline.
But there's more to it.
Tell us more.
FRANCOIS: So those
are my favorite,
and they deserve more
than two minutes for sure.
We'll do another video, I hope,
if you let me do one, please.
ALEXIS: Sure.
FRANCOIS: OK, so in a
nutshell, a Chrome packaged app
is a native application, built
with web technology, HTML5,
CSS feed, JavaScript.
It has a very, very strong
content security policy.
If you don't know what is a CSP,
please Google Mike West CSP,
and you will find tons of
YouTube videos for that.
That's really
important if you are
running a website right now.
You need to implement a CSP.
ALEXIS: So web sites
included, right?
FRANCOIS: Yes.
ALEXIS: This is not specific
to Chrome apps, extensions,
this is web.
And it's really something
you should look into.
FRANCOIS: So CSP,
very strong CSP.
And also you know they're
working offline, which
is very important, which means
when you download and install
a Chrome packaged app, it
comes with all the assets.
CSS, JavaScript, images,
blah, blah, blah.
And then, my favorite feature,
even though the web is great,
there is still some
stuff we can't do,
and that's why we
have the Chrome APIs.
And with those APIs, we
can access hardware devices
with USB, Bluetooth.
We can also play with
sockets, like raw sockets.
It's really, really cool.
Yeah, we need to talk--
ALEXIS: Yeah, we'll
get a chance, probably.
There is content online
already about chrome apps,
but we'll certainly talk more
about this in another episode.
What all of these
have in common,
so extensions and both
types of applications,
is that they're written in
the same set of technologies,
as you said, HTML5.
Tell us more about the
way you can develop them,
deploy them, package them.
Is it the same for
all of those as well?
FRANCOIS: For Chrome
packaged apps and extensions,
it's pretty easy.
If you have Chrome,
you have all the tools
you need to start creating one.
You just go to Chrome colon
slash slash extension,
and you check the
Developer Mode.
We actually showed that
in the previous video.
ALEXIS: The previous video, yes.
FRANCOIS: You click on the
Load Unpacked Extension.
You select your folder,
and bang, here you are.
You can start to debug and
develop your real extension
or application.
And if you want to deploy
it now, it's pretty easy.
You just zip it, upload it
to the Chrome Web Store,
and in a matter of
minutes, here you go.
ALEXIS: So what you're saying,
is the technology is the same,
packaging technologies
are the same,
and there's one place to
deploy all of those extensions
and apps.
That's the Chrome
Store, which by the way,
now supports a number
of new features
for monetizing your work.
That's great.
Maybe we should look into some
applications or some examples.
FRANCOIS: Let me show you some.
So let's play a little game.
What is it?
Is it an extension, a
hosted app, a packaged app?
ALEXIS: So we're looking at
something on the Chromebook
here, and this looks very much
like a packaged application.
FRANCOIS: It is, it's
actually the text application.
One little hint, you
can see the icon.
That means it's an application.
Still a package.
But you guessed it,
it's a packaged app.
Next one.
ALEXIS: That looks
very familiar.
I would say this is
a hosted application.
FRANCOIS: Why?
ALEXIS: Well, it could be
a packaged application,
it could be stand-alone,
but I don't know.
I had to make an educated guess.
FRANCOIS: Ok, so this is the
hosted app for Google Maps.
But yeah, like you say, it
could be a Chrome packaged app.
This is a classic
UI for a hosted app,
or for a packaged app.
What about this one?
ALEXIS: Could be a hosted app.
It doesn't look
like an extension,
because it seems to do a
whole lot more than just
extend the browser capability.
Stand-alone, I don't
know, packaged app.
FRANCOIS: Packaged app, yeah.
This application is
called CRC, and whoa,
this is a RSC client written
with web technologies.
So basically this guy just
[? reapplied ?] GDRC protocol.
This is pretty cool.
ALEXIS: Great.
So maybe something we could
talk about here at this point
is, where do all those live.
How can I manage those, look at
versions, install, uninstall?
Tell me more about this.
FRANCOIS: Pretty easy, actually.
If you go to Chrome dot
slash slash extensions,
you will see all your extensions
and your applications.
ALEXIS: OK.
FRANCOIS: Though the
name is not great here.
But you can also use the
Chrome app called Chrome Apps
Developer Tool, and it will list
all the applications in one tab
and all the extensions
in the other one.
ALEXIS: All the extensions.
Great.
And of course, all
applications can
be found on the App Launcher.
FRANCOIS: Yes.
ALEXIS: And maybe there's
a hint on which is which.
FRANCOIS: Yeah.
So you get all the
applications here,
but how do you know if it's
a hosted app or a packaged
app for sure?
Just right click on Application,
and if you see Open In New Tab,
Open In New Window,
Open Maximized,
this is a hosted app.
If not, this is a packaged app.
ALEXIS: OK, great.
Well, I think that's
all the time we have.
FRANCOIS: Yeah, sorry.
ALEXIS: This was
very quick, again.
We will spend more time
on Chrome packaged apps.
FRANCOIS: Hopefully.
ALEXIS: There is some
great stuff there.
But in the meantime,
thanks for watching,
and we'll be seeing
you in another episode.
Thank you, Francois.
FRANCOIS: Thanks.
ALEXIS: Cheers.